[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halweg guten Abend schön dass Sie dabei
sind wie auch Norbert König für den
Sport guten Abend Eispanzer war heute
einer der Begriffe des
Tages außergewöhnliches Winterwetter
Schneefall und Eisregen machen der Mitte
und dem Süden Deutschlands schwer zu
schaffen kleiner Vermittlungserfolg in
Nahost die Geiseln im Gazastreifen und
die palästinensische Bevölkerung dort
sollen Medikamente und Hilfsgüter
bekommen und erste Niederlage bei der
Handball EM deutschland verliert trotz
guter Leistung gegen Olympiasieger
Frankreich extremes Glatteis durch
gefrierenden Regen das hat heute weite
Teile Deutschlands ziemlich
beeinträchtigt Teile der A5 der A6 und
der A8 waren wegen eisglätter oder
Unfällen zeitweise gesperrt zahlreiche
Flüge und Zugverbindungen fielen aus
Warnungen gab es für die gesamte
Südhälfte des Landes vor großen
Schneemengen und vor allem vor diesem
Regen der Fahrbahnen und Gehwege in
Eisflächen verwandelte besonders
betroffen war ein Streifen von Trier bis
ins rheinmin Gebiet wo es stundenlang
regnete Stefan Schlösser fast den Tag
zusammen jeder Schritt eine heraus ung
im Süden Deutschlands ist der Regen
bereits am frühen Morgen angekommen und
hat eine dicke Eisschicht hinterlassen
ob Hauswände Zäune oder der Arm eines
anderen jede Stütze ist willkommen ohne
geht es nicht immer gut aus die
Winterdienste sind in weiten Teilen
Deutschland seit der Nacht im
Dauereinsatz doch sie könnne nicht
überall gleichzeitig sein wer unterwegs
war musste mehr Zeit einplanen wir sind
heute extra früher aufgestanden ich
hatte heute in der Früh schon das
Problem dass mein Auto eingefroren ist
ich musste mit M was soll das Auto frei
machen ähm es ist sehr glatt auf die
Nebenstraßen hier geht nichts mehr über
Stunden stauten sich hunderte LKW an der
Grenze nach Luxemburg das Land hatte
wegen des Eisregens ein Fahrverbot für
Fahrzeuge über 7,5 Tonnen
verhängt trotz zahlreicher Warnungen im
Vorfeld ist es zu vielen Unfällen
gekommen auf der A8 Richtung Stuttgart
kam ein Wagen mit Schleudern und
kollidierte mit einem LKW ein
nachfolgender Lkwfahrer hielt sofort an
um zu helfen und brachte sich damit
selbst in Gefahr LKW Fahrer ist
ausgestieger wahrscheinlich um a Hilfe
zu leisten und ist dabei dann von einem
weiteren Pkw erfasst worden angefahren
worden und dabei schwer verletzt worden
in der Eifel kam der Fahrer dieses
Kleintransporters in einer Kurve von der
rutschigen Straße ab und prallte gegen
einen Baum der 34-Jährige verstarb noch
an der Unfallstelle Einschränkungen auch
bei der Bahn wie hier in München fielen
zahlreiche Verbindungen aus größer noch
die Folgen für den Luftverkehr in
Frankfurt wurde schon im Vorfeld mehr
als die Hälfte aller Flüge gestrichen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen setzte am Nachmittag
der große Schneefall ein in Köln zeigte
sich der Winter so auch von seiner
schönen Seite Schneeballschlacht
inklusive und nach Frankfurt am Main an
den Flughafen schauen wir jetzt noch mal
hin dort konnte heute zeitweise kein
Flugzeug mehr starten Markus wolsffer
wie läuft es
mittlerweile viel Frust hier am
Frankfurter Flughafen wir sind hier in
Terminal 1 Halle A und natürlich die
Menschen sind frustriert viele kommen
viel später ans Ziel als ursprünglich
geplant die lufthanser hat hier
beispielsweise einige Snacks und
Getränke hingestellt das ist natürlich
wichtig für all jene die stundenlang
ausharen müssen wir hatten Gelegenheit
mit einigen zu sprechen das waren
teilweise emotionale Szenen eine Frau
hat berichtet dass sie wahrscheinlich
die Hochzeit ihres Sohnes morgen
verpassen werde besonders betroffen auch
viele internationale Reisende die fragen
sich natürlich wie geht es ist weiter wo
komme ich unter fraport hat angekündigt
einige Feldbetten zur Verfügung zu
stellen es gibt do ein gewisses
hotelkontingent aber das ist natürlich
irgendwann auch zu Ende inzwischen ist
bekannt dass punktuell gibt es
staatsundlandungen das ist aber
verglichen mit sonst verschwindend
gering normalerweise wären das heute
1100 Flugbewegungen gewesen am Ende ist
es ein Bruchteil davon ein schwieriger
Tag heute und wahrscheinlich geht's
morgen auch schwierig weiter danke schön
für diese Eindrücke vom Frankfurter
Flughafen markus wolseffer war das viele
haben sich nach den Warnungen auf die
besondere Wetterlage eingestellt Schulen
und Kitas blieben geschlossen
Unternehmen ließen ihre Belegschaft wenn
möglich von zu Hause aus arbeiten aber
manche mussten einfach raus um ihre
Patienten nicht im Stich zu lassen zeigt
Thomas
gons Pflegerinnen und Pfleger auf
eisigen wegen Medikamente bringen
Menschen versorgen jetzt am Nachmittag
geht's am Morgen aber war das im saarand
kaum oder gar nicht möglich ambulante
Behandlung
ausgebremst gerade im im ländlichen
Bereich haben wir halt viele Straßen
viele Hügel und dort ist es halt
wirklich schwierig dort den Berg hoch
oder den Berg runterzukommen dort sind
vier oder fünf Autos von uns liegen
geblieben wir mussten ganz viele
Einsätze tatsächlich von unseren Kunden
Absagen kein gewöhnlicher Mitwoch auch
in Kliniken immer mehr Unfälle immer
mehr Patienten die sabrücker Notaufnahme
fast selbst im Notmodus wir haben zwar
viele Patienten jetzt auch
unfallchirurgisch viele Stürze Patienten
die umgeknickt sind aber wir konnten
jeden versorgen und es war Gott sei Dank
keine schlimmere Verletzung dabei bisher
viele Notfälle wenig Personal eben auch
wegen des eischaos in einigen
Krankenhäusern ein Problem hier hat man
sich
vorbereitet sich mer Notfälle als als
sonst wir haben aber unseren geplanten
OP bei höftprothesen Knieprothesen
schulterpr Prothesen
die also reduziert damit wir nur
unfallchirurgische Patienten versorgen
normalerweise arbeiten wir
50 aber im Moment nur unfallchirurgische
Seele laufen weniger gut läuft in
eisglatten Innenstädten geschlossen
blieben daher einige Geschäfte wie in
trie zu hatten auch etliche Kitas und
Schulen etwa im Raum Fulda draußen
Schnee innen lere Kinder und Jugendliche
haben eisfrei besser Unfälle vermeiden
als Unterricht auch Unis ließen verstal
ausfallen in Bonn hieß es Schneemann
bauen geht über Studieren insgesamt
blieb das große Chaos aus auch weil
viele schlicht zu Hause blieben und die
Infrastruktur sie zeigt sich bislang
winterfest katja horonneifer ist wieder
hier aus unserer Wetterredaktion guten
Abend katja ist das Schlimmste
überstanden das allerschlimmste ist wohl
überstanden jedenfalls warn der Deutsche
Wetterdienst nicht mehr mit extremen
Unwetterwarnungen sondern in
anführungstrichen nur noch mit
Unwetterwarnungen die laufen allerdings
und dafür haben wir auch eine Karte
vorbereitet noch bis morgen früh 4 Uhr
vor gefrierendem Regen und den gibt es
vor allen Dingen in einem breiten
Streifen von Rheinland-Pfalz bis nach
Thüringen und Sachsen und nach Bayern
und nördlich davon gibt's Schneefälle
und diese Schneefälle halten auch noch
bis 9 Uhr an und erst morgen übertag
entspannt sich die Lage langsam wenn
nicht Schnee und Regen langsam aber
sicher Richtung Südosten Deutschland
verlassenm wie ungewöhnlich ist die
diese Wetterlage die wir gerade haben
wir haben es mit einer grenzwetterlage
zu tun da gab es sehr kalte Luft von
Norden und dann diese milde feuchte Luft
von Südwesten grenzwetterlagen sind gar
nicht so ungewöhnlich die einigen von
uns erinnern sich wahrscheinlich noch
Anfang Dezember gab es auch eine
grenzwetterlage da hat es diesen
kräftigen Schneefall in München gegeben
40 cm was man da auch nicht oft hat aber
eine so flächendeckende
glatteiswetterlage die ist wirklich
ungewöhnlich der Deutsche Wetterdienst
sagt das gab es zuletzt
1987 das also schon eine ganze Zeit lang
her absolut danke schön Katja hornffer
für den Moment du bist nachher wieder
dran und wie es zur aktuellen
unwetterlage kommt wie lange sie noch
anhält und wo es noch glatt werden
könnte all das können sie noch mal in
Ruhe bei uns online nachlesen unter
zf.de nach dem Geheimtreffen von
Rechtsextremisten an dem auch AFD
Politiker teilnahmen gehen immer mehr
Menschen auf die Straße gestern Abend
demonstrierten 10ta000 in Köln gegen
Hass und Hetze im onlineienst X begrüßte
Bundeskanzler Scholz die Proteste als
Mutmacher auch der Innenausschuss des
Bundestags beschäftigte sich mit der
Recherche von Korrektiv die Journalisten
hatten zuerst über das Treffen berichtet
Andrea
Maura seit einer Stunde gehen sie in
Berlin gegen Rechts auf die Straße die
Menschen hier zeigen sich erschüttert
darüber dass rechtsextreme mit AFD und
CDU Mitgliedern über deportationspläne
gesprochen haben sollen am Vormittag hat
hat der Verfassungsschutz den
Innenausschuss über seine Erkenntnisse
informiert mehrere Teilnehmer des
Treffens waren dem Verfassungsschutz
bekannt insgesamt zeigt sich dass
dies eines von mehreren Schlaglichtern
darauf ist dass sich die rechtsextreme
Szene in Deutschland untereinander
vernetzt und dass die AFD dort
regelmäßig dabei ist die AFD
argumentiert der Verfassungsschutz könne
nicht nachweisen dass AFD Mitglieder die
deportationspläne von Martin selner
Aktivist der rechtsextrem identitären
Bewegung unterstützt hätten und
Remigration so interpretierten wie er
der entscheidende Punkt ist für die
kruden über begriffsübersteuerung des
ib-aktivisten konnte an keiner Stelle
oder wollte an keiner Stelle belegbar
behauptet werden dass AFD Vertreter
diese mittrügen es wurde gezielt zu
diesem Treffen eingeladen um mit Herrn
selner über sein Buch zu sprechen da
stehen keine Dinge drin die ganz
verhamlos über die Rückführung von
illegal sich hier aufhallenden Menschen
spricht sondern über ganz
unterschiedliche Personengruppen die
unter anderem auch Menschen wie mich
betreffen also Menschen die deutsche
sind in deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit
haben und die hier zwangsdeportiert
werden sollen die neuen Erkenntnisse
befeuern nun die Debatte über ein AFD
Verbotsverfahren deswegen ist das ein
weiterer Schritt auch was die Verfahren
ein Frage eines Verbotsverfahrens angeht
ein zentraler Baustein war notwendig
dass der Innenausschuss sich hiermit
beschäftigt auch ein Einreiseverbot für
den österreichischen Staatsbürger selner
will die Regierung offenbar
Prüfen schauen wir in den Nahen Osten da
gibt es heute etwas Erleichterung im
seit drei Monaten umkämpften
Gazastreifen dank einer mühsam auf den
Weg gebrachten Vereinbarung zwischen
Israel und der Terrororganisation Hamas
ein Konvoi soll von Ägypten aus den
festgehaltenen israelischen Geiseln
dringend benötigte Medikamente bringen
im Gegenzug bekommt auch die
palästinensische Zivilbevölkerung
weitere humanitäre Hilfe
die Kämpfe gehen da weil weiter
lwalpott Israels Armee griff auch in der
vergangenen Nacht wieder Ziele im
südlichen Gazastreifen an nach
israelischen Angaben sollen sich dort in
der Nähe des Nassa Krankenhauses
führende hamaskämpfer und verschleppte
Geiseln aufhalten auch Gebäude in Rafa
an der ägyptischen grönze und das
jordanische feldlzaret wurden dabei
beschädigt das hier soll also jetzt die
sichere Zone Raffa sein die Menschen
gehen abends zu Hause ins Bett und
Wachen am nächsten Morgen im Friedhof
auf hier sterben Kinder wie kann das
sein warum lässt die Welt das
zu nach palästinensischen Angaben wurden
allein seit gestern
163 Menschen getötet unabhängig
überprüfen lassen sich die Zahlen nicht
an Ende des Krieges sei noch nicht in
Sicht sagte ein israelischer
Regierungssprecher solange Hamas Gaza im
Würgegriff hält und unschuldige Bürger
in Israel bedroht haben wir keine Wahl
wir müssen sie
vernichten Gewalt und tote auch im
Westjordanland wo Israels Streitkräfte
bei luftanschlägen mindestens neun
Menschen töteten palästinensische
Kämpfer die Anschläge vorbereitet haben
sollen so die israelische
Darstellung unterdessen trafen in
Ägypten medizinische Hilfsgüter ein auf
Initiative von Frankreich und Katar
sollen die Medikamente über das Rote
Kreuz und die Hamas zu den mehr als 100
israelischen Geiseln gelangen von denen
rund die Hälfte Krone krank ist auch ein
Lichtblick für die notleidende
Bevölkerung in Gaza die ebenfalls
weitere Medikamente und Nahrung erhalten
soll in die Ukraine dort hat die
russische Armee in der Nacht wieder
zahlreiche Regionen mit Drohnen und
Raketen aus der Luft angegriffen in
harkev wurde ein Wohngebäude getroffen
nach ukrainischen Angaben wurden
mindestens 17 Menschen verletzt zwei
davon schwer 19 von insgesamt 20 Drohnen
sein abgewehrt worden die Behörden
berichten von Schäden an ausschließlich
ziviler
Infrastruktur in Russland ist der
Protest gegen die Regierung weitgehend
verstummt doch jetzt regt sich in einer
Teilrepublik Widerstand einer der
größten seit langem mehrere tausend
Menschen haben in
baskortostan gegen die Verurteilung
eines lokalen Ökoaktivisten demonstriert
angeblich wegen rassistischer Äußerungen
erhielt er vier Jahre Haft der Mann war
bereits vor gut einem Jahr zu einer
Geldstrafe verurteilt worden weil er den
Krieg kritisiert
hatte weniger Fleisch und zuckerhaltige
Lebensmittel dafür mehr Obst und Gemüse
besonders in Kitas und Schulkantinen
diese Ernährungsstrategie hat die
Bundesregierung beschlossen neue
Qualitätsstandards sollen vor allem bei
der
außerhausverpflegung greifen die Ziele
sind bis
2050 also eher langfristig
gesetzt wie umgehen mit künstlicher
Intelligenz diese Frage stellen Sie sich
auch Schüler Studierende und Lehrer
heute legten die Bildungsexperten der
Kultusministerkonferenz ihre
Einschätzung vor danach bietet KI großes
Potenzial im Bildungsbereich allerdings
nur unter bestimmten Bedingungen an den
Hochschulen z.B müssen auch Prüfungen
angepasst werden Luisa Huben hat
mehr Dozentin Angelika zirker weiß dass
ich ihre Studierenden von Programmen wie
chatgpt ihre Hausarbeiten schreiben
lassen könnten und genau deswegen gibt
sie ihnen d Aufgaben es ist wichtig eben
Studierende auch zu sensibilisieren und
damit produktiv und auch proaktiv
umzugehen und eben nicht zu sagen wir
verbieten das von vorne rein sondern
auch den Studierenden zu zeigen welche
Möglichkeiten es eröffnet und wo aber
eben auch die Grenzen liegen in ihrem
literaturseminar sollen die Studierenden
der KI Forschungsfragen stellen und die
Antwort kritisch bewerten denn nicht
selten halluziniert das Programm dann
klingt der generierte Text zwar gut ist
aber fehlerhaft nicht so nützlich als
dass ich das Ding meine Hausarbeit
schreiben lassen würde und was
Quellenangaben angeht und ein bisschen
wackelig ich glaube auch dass die Linie
relativ fein ist zwischen akademisch
verwendbar und vertretbar moralisch auch
und es ist eigentlich schon fast betrug
auch Urheberrechts und Datenschutzfragen
sind bisher ungeklärt doch trotz aller
Bedenken bildungsexpertinnen und
Experten ermutigen nun die kitools
einzusetzen und fordern neue
Prüfungsformen die sicherstellen dass
Studierende und Schüler trotz der
Hilfsmittel etwas lernen da kommt die
Lehrerbildung ins spielel dass wir ganz
klar Aufgabenformate brauchen und in den
es nicht drum geht dass ein Kind ein
gutes Produkt erstellt Text s dass der
Prozess der Denkprozess aktiviert wird
Programme wie chatgpt sein vergleichbar
mit dem Taschenrechner jeder sollte das
Hilfsmittel sinnvoll nutzen können
gleichzeitig bleibe wichtig Aufgaben
auch ohne lösen zu
können eine weitere schlappe vor Gericht
für VW Dieselmodelle des
Volkswagenkonzerns sein weiterhin mit
unzulässigen abschalteinrichtungen
ausgestattet das urteilte das
Verwaltungsgericht Schleswig geklagt
hatte die Deutsche Umwelthilfe die sich
vor einem Jahr bereits in einem
ähnlichen Fall in erster Instanz
durchsetzen konnte VW kündigte auch
gegen das aktuelle Urteil Rechtsmittel
an gute und schlechte Nachrichten in
Sachen Rauchen weltweit sagt die WHO
würde immer weniger geraucht aber Europa
hinke hinterher besonders sorgt sich die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation um
Jugendliche die Tabakindustrie würde
systematisch sogar Grundschulkinder
abhängig machen so ihr Vorwurf etwa
durch E-Zigaretten mit
Geschmacksrichtungen wie Vanilleeis oder
Gummibärchen schon bei den 13 bis
15-Jährigen konsumiere eins von Zeh
Kindern weltweit Tabak kastenbären zeigt
mit welchen Projekten Berlin
gegensteuert cool aussehen wie auf einem
Werbeplakat das geht auch mit Lolli
statt Zigarette im Mund das sieht voll
gut aus das sieh richtig gut aus
spielerisch lernen die sechsglässler an
der Berliner Anne frankchule Nein zu
sagen zum
Nikotin ich möchte nicht dass viele
Kinder anfangen zu rauchen auch im
jungen Alter weil es ist nicht gut im 20
Jahrhundert war es ja auch oft so dass
viele Leute einfach so geraucht haben
ohne überhaupt
nachzudenken das workshopteam der
Berliner hat ein Experiment mitgebracht
der Glaskolben stellt die Lunge da der
Watte bauscht darin das Lungengewebe
schon nach einer halben Zigarette ist er
gelb und schwarz die Botschaft jede
Rauchmenge schadet dem
Körper wir kriegen halt mit ist ein
Thema ist was in dem Alter schon total
relevant ist auch wenn man das
vielleicht erste mal nicht so denkt aber
das ist schon das Alter wo die damit
anfangen seit 2021 ist der Anteil
rauchender Kinder und Jugendlicher
sprungft angestiegen
b eZigaretten undap mit vermeintlich
harmlosen Fruchtaromen jedes vierte Kind
zwischen 9 und 17 Jahren habe schon
mindestens einmal daran gezogen wenn man
so früh beginnt mitm rauchen dann hat
man wesentlich höhere Risiken für
chronische Erkrankungen wie
Krebserkrankungen auch
Herzkreislauferkrankungen sind
wesentlich
erhöht im Rollenspiel len die Schüler
Gruppendruck zu widerstehen damit sie
mit demuchen mögst gar nicht
anfangen und jetzt Handball die erste em
Niederlage fürs deutsche Team Norbert
ist aber noch kein Drama nee das
Halbfinale ist weiterhin absolut
realistisches Ziel und gegen
Olympiasieger Frankreich darf man ja
auch mal verlieren allerdings sollte es
nach dem Berliner
30:33 jetzt in der Hauptrunde in Köln
keine weitere Niederlage
geben die Roten Funken stehen Spalier
und begrüßen das drbteam wie es sich
gehört mit einem dreifachen Kölle
al die fünstündige Zugfahrt zuvor aus
Berlin haben Sie nicht nur genutzt um
sich etwas abzulenken sondern auch um
die Versäumnisse der Niederlage gegen
Frankreich aufzuarbeiten gut 11 Minuten
vor dem Ende geht der EM Gastgeber
letztmals in Führung Sebastian Heimann
mit dem 27
z26 danach einige unnötige
Ballverluste und zu viele leichte
Gegentore der
Franzosen nun geht's morgen also gegen
Island wenn man so will das erste
Endspiel wir haben jetzt die klare
marschrout wir haben alles in der
eigenen Hand wir müssen alles gewinnen
und da freuen wir uns drauf vor vor
dieser Atmosphäre hier in Köln ja zu
spielen und abzuliefern hoffentlich das
Abschlusstraining vor einer Stunde die
Vorfreude sie ist
unübersehbar bei den Australian Open der
Tennisprofis hat Tamara korpat die
dritte Runde verpasst 2 Z6 und 2:6 gegen
die tschechenin
kreekova auch Laura Siegemund muss jetzt
im Einzel zuschauen nach ihrer
überraschenden Niederlage gegen die
Australierin Storm
Hunter allzu selten bringt die Kämpferin
Laura sieegem und Schläge zustande wie
den zum
Satzausgleich 6:3 im zweiten ihre
Analyse ist kurz und treffend zu viele
Fehler gemacht ganz klar ich habe heute
leider keinen sonderlich guten Tag
erwischt muss man ganz klar sagen
natürlich liegt es auch an der Gegnerin
Storm Hunter erwischt einen ihrer besten
Tage die australische Qualifikantin
dreht im dritten Satz noch einmal
richtig auf am Ende heißt es 6:3 für die
lokalmadorin Laura Siegemund braucht
aber noch nicht endgültig ihre Sachen zu
packen im Doppel und im mixt warten
weitere Aufgaben auf
sie mal sehen wie wie lange Frau Hunter
noch das Turnier stürmt der der Name
gefällt dir ne ja dir auch oder mir auch
fehlt noch Lotto die Gewinnzahlen lauten
69 13 30 40 44 und die Superzahl 6
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
557 Wetter ist ja das Thema in diesen
Stunden von Katja hornffer erfahren Sie
auch gleich noch etwas über die weiteren
Aussichten Dunja Hayali begrüßt sie um
:4 Uhr im heute journal wir wünschen
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend von Südwesten ist
Regen herangezogen und der ist über die
Eiseskälte am Boden gezogen so hatte das
Glatteis stundenlang Zeit sich auf
auszubilden nördlich davon hat es
kräftig geschneit das sehen Sie hier in
der rosa Farbe und auch jetzt am Abend
schneit es noch kräftig weiter in diesem
Gebiet ungefähr von der Eifel bis zum
Thüringerwald und auch Glatteis gibt es
immer noch zwischen Rheinlandpfalz und
Thüringen im Laufe der Nacht wird dieses
schmale Band mit Glatteis aber immer
dünner es bleibt allerdings bei den
kräftigen Schneefällen und auch über
Norddeutschland ziehen einige
Schneeschauer hinweg und dann kann es
natürlich auch dort glatt sein denn die
Temperaturen sinken zumeist auf 0 bis
-5° im Südwesten bleibt die Nacht bei +
8° deutlich milder morgen zu Beginn des
Berufsverkehrs sollten Sie sich auf
Schneefälle Einstellen von
Rheinlandpfalz bis nach Sachsen und ins
südliche Brandenburg im Laufe des Tages
aber ziehen Schnee und Regen in Richtung
Südosten aus Deutschland raus und dann
wird es ganz freundlich in einem breiten
Streifen von der Ostseeküste bis zur
Mosel der Winter hat schon auf nördliche
Richtungen gedreht so liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen Morgen meist bei -1
bis + 3° 10° werden es am oberrein und
deutlich ruhiger wird's dann zum
Wochenende guten Abend